so I saw the new Star Wars film this
weekend and I've got some issues
seriously if you haven't seen the movie
yet I'm gonna spoil all of it I'm a Star
Wars fan but I think it's far from a
perfect series and there were a lot of
things about the last Jedi I liked like
kylo and Ray taking on Snoke puppet Yoda
but at the same time there were a lot of
things I did not care for first the
entire Finn plot was right a lot of the
film is dedicated to this plotline and
it never works out the plan fails and
its failure has no effect on the rest of
the story and seriously the whole
plotline would have been solved if Finn
and Rose just took a few minutes to find
a parking spot next Leia super Manning
through space third and this is a big
one for me when did Jedi suddenly have
unlimited power
Rey and kylo spend most of this film
force facetiming with each other and
Luke suddenly has the ability to project
his spirit worlds away from his actual
location when did these become things
fourth Laura Dern's entire existence why
is she in this movie and why does her
character look like she fell out of the
Hunger Games franchise admirable Akbar
should have been the one that took
control of the resistance and he should
have been the one that went on the
suicide mission because that way we
would have cared
next pork's and crystal means shut up
and lastly the end of the film Luke just
disappears really like I get it Luke
can't live up to his own legend and
there's also an argument for religious
allegory
la blah blah Luke is one of the greatest
heroes and cinematic history and the guy
just fades away into a sunset because
he's exhausted oh and look milking that
cow Vic what was that
[Music]